there we go yep cool
fire drums 2014 workshop review three
club triads and tribrids
a uh triad is a club
shape or manipulation when the knobs are
in together
so once the hands break apart i no
longer have a triad
per se so all of the tricks that we were
learning in this workshop
can be done with the hands together
so the first tricks we did were triad
spinning
patterns tried spinning patterns because
it's also a tribe by side note the
green club is doing an isolation the red
club is doing an extension and the
yellow club is doing
a horizontal line you can do the annie
spin with the
outer club of the one club hand and you
can switch
which club is doing the anderson yellow
club red club
yellow club red club we also did
vertical anti-spins we did statics
static vertical static horizontal
switching switching between
static positions like floats we did
curves when you have an extension like
that if you create a 90 degree
relationship with the
crop you can do quick curves on
different planes
birds and static work in tandem
and we did some dob switch spinning
patterns where we're doing this remember
if you're
doing this pattern with the fingers
locked like that we highly recommend
this open position like this
dob switch dot referring to double knob
so we have
iso and extension with the one club cap
iso horizontal antispan
there's one you can turn it um
brian thompson this wasn't in the
workshop but we'll add it
doing we're doing this and a vertical
antispin
so those are some more spinning patterns
then we went on to
uh again referring to we have the three
objects
in spin oh what whatever they're doing
oh i'm going to mention this because
this is important every triad spinning
pattern
is a reflection of the other three
timing and directions my hands are in
together same
but i can do the exact same pattern with
all the clubs doing the same type of
spin
in different hand timings and directions
and so what i love it because in in the
triads they all reflect
three other patterns each triad spinning
pattern can be done three other ways
essentially triad weaving
one in the pocket as we say reverse
weave
forward weave noticing that i'm doing it
really close into my body
the reason for that is it makes it
easier as soon as i have my hands out
here
it's more tension on the hands it's
harder to keep the one club inside
so i'm bringing it in close to my body
reverse and forward
then we did triad weaving legos where
weaving
we then brought it into the pocket
instead of a round yellow club goes into
the pocket instead of around
comes around into the pocket and we can
pass off
the inside club of the two club hand so
now
so many things oh we did the the actual
the
knob the triad legos themselves uh
classic we're sort of the cascade of the
dog legos here
the inside club of the two club hand is
dropping out the key here the key here
is going into the position like this
if you bring the one club hand up and
you're in a thumb set
you got problems so it needs to come up
into the two finger
position so regular
reverse then we did the same direction
where the clubs are spinning in the same
direction
doing a few variations that we didn't
quite cover but
the one in the workshop was this
club one hand club drops inside
outside club of the club hand up in the
same direction
placing the switch oops one
two we can do the triad legos out here
instead of down here
we did this one where the one club hand
drops inside and the other one drops in
the opposite direction on the outside
of the one club arm
we can also do these in different
directions i can do opposite direction
over the top
opposite direction on the bottom same
direction
either way with the lego switches and
you can see how that would
integrate into the weaving and such
triad buzz saws the next category we did
key elements here is this l grip
you have the forward and the reverse
for the reverse buzz saw i'm in this
forward l grip here
holding the club down all the way down
in the two fingers i'm going to use my
thumb
to hook in and push it up once i've
taken it into l grip again with the
other hand
i allow this to fall down
like such get your thumb out of the way
use the thumb lift up the next one
l grip this one falls down l grip
falls down and this is the forward
pardon me
i'm getting so proficient i get confused
now that's great
the reverse
l grip the horizontal club facing out
dropping it to the inside like that
again you're going l grip
to l grip
and forward is starting with the inside
l grip thumb hooks
transitions always with the two club
hand on the outside or the side you're
turning away from
as soon as my left hand has two clubs i
can turn this way
as soon as my right hand has two clubs i
we did some darting which is like a
triad
hobby style where one moves you can dart
through a line
i mean here i have a line a three-point
frame of reference back to another line
uh we did some fun fishy stuff that's
the main problem
so those are the major categories that
all blend together
and the transition points are uh
plentiful and whether it's a lego or a
spin
pattern or a tribrid or just a static
shape
it's a great style of club manipulation
and it's all torch friendly
not once in this workshop did we grab
the body of a club
or the cap of a club which makes it
tough for torch
juggling i hope you've enjoyed triads
and tributes i'm kevin axtell
thanks guys
kevin excel please try ads and try
braids happy to break down any fire
drums